Y P you know, millennials and gen Z ears are, are re,
are reconnecting with the church or connecting for the first time to faith. Uh,
I think large in part due to the failure, you know,
perhaps of, of, of, of secularism it doesn't work.
Um, and there's questions. I think that, that it's attempted to answer it,
that it hasn't answered.
And that's why you leave and see guys like Sam Harris who have become spiritual,
not in any sort of Orthodox sense,
but an awareness that maybe there is something out there that aren't,
we connect to and soul and spirit, et cetera.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report. Quick reminder,
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube channel and click that pesky notification
bell. And joining me today is an author and a teaching pastor. Nathan.
Pinoccio welcome to the Rubin report.
I'm glad to have you, sir, because as you probably know,
I do some talking to people of faith, people, uh, uh,
better skeptics people that are somewhere in between.
And I always find these to be sort of the most interesting conversations that I
have. So before we do anything about what you're doing now,
tell me a little bit about your journey to faith.
Yeah. So, uh, I'm the son of a preacher man.
My dad has been in the ministry as long as I could remember. Um,
and I've sort of just fallen into it to be quite honest. I,
I tried to kind of not necessarily run the other way,
but do something else and sort of just caught up to me, you know, it's like,
you know, so it just kind of, uh, this is what I do now.
Cause it's just kind of what I, what I know, but I do. Um,
I do have, I've always had a kind of strong faith in God.
I just never saw myself as the ministerial type because you know,
like people of faith, I guess, spiritual leaders,
they kind of have a type. And in my opinion, they're, they're my opinion.
They're, they're kind of square and they stay home on Friday nights and play
Scrabble with grandma. And it was just not what I wanted to do with my life.
You know?
Hey, don't knock Scrabble, man. Everybody loves Scrabble.
Look, I take that back. Okay. Scrapple is crate and grandma's wonderful.
Uh, well, to your point though, you kinda it's like, well, wait a minute,
look at this guy. He doesn't really look like a pastor.
And then on the other hand, you look like sort of a modern Jesus. So you're,
you're sort of doing a little everything over there.
Um, uh, it's, you know, it's a work in progress.
Um, did you, on the way, you said you did a little something, uh,
before going into this, even though you came from a family of faith, uh,
was the faith part always there,
or did you mean that you deviated from that too?
Or did you just mean that sort of career-wise or something?
I just meant that sort of career wise? Yeah, I was doing music, um,
for about eight years. And, um, so yeah,
it's kind of doing that and things just didn't work out the way I kind of wanted
them to work out. I sort of went back to, uh,
went back to the family farm, so to speak.
And so I'm just kind of doing ministry now for the last gosh, I don't know,
uh, last six years.
So if somebody said to you sort of lay out what your belief system
is, what would that be? Kind of broadly speaking.
Yeah. So I'm a, I'm a confessional Christian. Um, that's what I'd say.
Um, uh, in the, uh, kind of the brand of Christianity that,
um, or the stream that I flow in, it's more of a Pentecostal Christianity,
you know? So we're the ones that, um, I mean, I've never handled a snake before,
but that's kind of what Pentecostals are known for, you know,
Tamborine destroying Pentecostals were the ones that when you
go to our churches on the weekend, um, it's kind of like a rock concert. Um,
so we've got lasers and, you know, we, we kind of attract a younger crowd. Uh,
but our idea basically is that we have a,
a historic Orthodox confessional, um,
Christian doctrine.
So we believe that the stuff that the church has always believed, um,
and we confess and we profess that. Uh, but the, we wrap it up,
um, in sort of a modern, um, in a modern vibe.
Yeah. Do you get a lot of pushback on that? Sort of,
I've seen this in a few different versions where there's, you know,
the sort of belief that you just have to have the belief and the,
the orthodoxy and the conservative look at religion,
and then you bring in music, you bring in lasers,
you bring in bands and all sorts of other stuff. And people,
a certain set of people will think that that will kind of erode the original
message.
Yeah. Um, yeah,
I think that that's utter and total ridiculousness, um,
basically, I mean,
look at Vatican three and kind of what the Catholic church has done,
like is having services in English somehow diminish
the Catholic churches, you know, their their message. No, it doesn't.
So that's essentially what we're doing, where,
whereas they're just there for them.
Progress is translating the mass from Latin to English for us. We're,
we're doing exactly that. We're translating the message, but like, you know,
the currency, I think of our generation is music and the arts.
And so that's kind of how we, uh, we communicated that language.
Right? So sort of speaking of music and the arts,
what kind of put you on my radar is that, uh,
Justin Bieber is a member of the church. I don't want you to get into any,
any specifics about anyone that goes to the church, but,
but what do you sense is happening with people of his
age related to belief? There does seem to be something going on, you know,
Kanye is running these services now and, you know, as you just said,
it's sort of related to music and culture and something else.
It's not what we think of when we just think of like the traditional religious
perspective.
Yeah, yeah. A hundred percent. I think that people,
I know you mentioned Justin and Kanye. Um, as far as I know,
they had church upbringings. Um,
so there's a lot of people come up in the church. Um,
I know Justin for a fact did, um, I went to,
I spoke at his home church in Canada.
I'm actually Canadian I've I grew up 45 minutes from where he grew up.
Um, so I know like, I mean, Elvis for crying out loud,
you know, came up in the churches.
It's not uncommon in the American story that people in the arts come up in
church and then they kind of leave the small town and they go do big musical
things. So, um, but in terms of a return, I mean,
we saw it even in Elvis's career, you know,
the only album that ever won a Grammy for, uh, was for his gospel record.
So there's something I think, intrinsic to, um, Americana
and the church and music. Um, so it's a pretty common, common theme.
Why, you know, millennials and gen Z years are, are re,
are reconnecting with the church or connecting for the first time to faith. Uh,
I think large in part due to the failure, you know,
perhaps of, of, of secularism it, it doesn't work.
Um, and there's questions. I think that,
that it's attempted to answer that it hasn't answered.
And that's why you leave and see guys like Sam Harris who have become spiritual,
not in any sort of Orthodox sense,
but an awareness that maybe there is something out there that aren't,
we connect to and soul and spirit, et cetera. Um,
so I think we have something to offer people, um, that is,
that is reasonable. Um, um,
and that is also experiential. So.
One of the things that I've been talking about on the show a lot lately is that
I think a lot of the problems we're having is that we seem to be reaching the
end of secularism,
which I think is sort of what you're alluding to that when you get to the end of
pure secularism with nothing else outside of itself,
that everything's on the table again.
And we don't know if men are men and women are women and we're debating
destroying, you know,
our past in the name of some utopian future and the rest of it.
Do you see that as just like the natural kind of outgrowth of what, uh,
what a purely secular society is?
Yeah, I think, um, gosh, you know, without getting into a huge history lesson,
um, w what I would call, I think there's two types of,
of there's two types of people in our churches right now. Okay.
There's what we would make, might call leftists, um,
and a secular be a secularist might be a better term. Um, but,
and then we have, you know, for lack of a better term, a conservative,
which I can't stand the term, but, um, but just using generalizations.
And what I think has happened as a society is that we have an epistemological
crisis. That's kind of what happened with what has happened,
because secularism is the idea, essentially,
that material is the only thing that you can touch. And we could all,
we should all live together in our material society. Um,
and let's forget about things that are not, are, non-material like spirituality,
because those things will just divide us. And it was kind of,
it kind of works out at first, but then, um,
it begins to hammer down everybody into just material and people aren't just
material and the world. Isn't just material. There's a lot more to it.
For more honest and thoughtful conversations about spirituality instead of
nonstop yelling, check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.